عندي احد حابب يسلم عليك معنا النجمه مي
كساب هي انتم ما جمعتكم الى الان اي مشاهد
في المسلسل ولكن هي موجوده معانا مي اذا
حابه تقولي لاحمد شيء او حابين انتم
الاثنين تكشفوا لنا اي سر
احنا لا يمكن
ضميرنا المهني ابدا طيب بس هتلاقوا في
المسلسل لاحقا كيف كان الشغل معك الله
اعلم الله اعلم الله اعلم طيب خلاص برافو
عليك يا ههه مي لانه التوقعات شغاله على
السوشيال ميديا على ده الموضوع
دق جمهور الجمهور قاتلني من كومنتاته بجد
بيضحكوني بموت بيضحك واحمد انت اكيد جايتك
نفس التعليقات بتسالك على الموضوع
اكيد وهو وهو
محمد سامي نفسه هو كان قاصد اللي بيحصل
دلوقتي ده هو كان نفسه ان هو يحصل وهو
محضر له يعني الاسئله اللي بتتسال دلوقتي
هو كان قاصد انه يخلي الناس تسالها فده
حاجه لذيذه انك تشوف المكان المخرج نفسه
يحصل بيحصل دي حاجه جميله يعني
عشان تعرفي ان انت غاليه في مفاجاه في
حلقه بكره اهو حلو اهو خبر عشان خاطرك
طيب احنا ما شفناشكرك واذا محمد سامي زعل
منك خليه يكلمنا نحن نعتذر منه
الف مبروك على الصندوق ومبروك على جعفر
العمده وهو عارف انا بحبه قد ايه وممثل
شاطر وموهبه كبيره قوي قوي
مبروك علينا مبروك علينا وطبعا يعني ما
يكسب ولا انبسطت جدا بالشغل معاها
كانت حلوه المسلسل كله بقيناش
طيب احمد انت هتفضل معانا ماي حابين نشكرك
شكرا جزيلا حبيبتي وبالتوفيق دائما في كل
اعمالك واشوفك الرمضان الجاي ان شاء الله
وانت منجمه اكثر واكثر كانت معنا ما يتكسر
شكرا لك